what is it about a certain location a
cipher may be the physical beauty of it
do you almost feel that there's some
sense of I don't know is there some
other sense that you pick up from going
to a certain location or it's just well
I I think it's a way of getting to know
a place and maybe because I grew up in
the Midwest and kind of you know
circumscribed by the Mississippi and
Missouri rivers and some st. Louis you
know going to exotic places was
something I kind of dreamed about but
never really thought it could happen and
so maybe this is kind of an extension of
childhood dreams but the unintended
consequence of shooting in these places
that have locations that have really
thrilled me is it's a way of getting to
know the people the culture by being
part of it
however you know remote I am because I'm
not from that region there is something
that I know which is how to make a film
and there's something I don't know which
is how do they make films in that
country or in that region and for
example I worked with a Peruvian lucha
Yosa and made a film they're called
Max's missing and what I saw with his
crew who were not terribly experienced
for the most part is that they
functioned like a family everybody
supporting everybody else
nobody's saying that's your job if
something had to be done and there was a
kind of respect they had for Lucho as
the sort of father figure which is I
think maybe common or maybe this is my
conjecture in Latin American countries
and the combination of the respect they
had for Lucho not that he was giving
orders but they that they wanted to do
well for him and the way that they
worked as if they were kind of brothers
sisters cousins to provide what needed
to be provided for the film was quite
lovely do you think that exists in
American cinema
I think it can I think it can exist
probably more more likely with a
director everyone is like desperately
wanting to work with because they
respect his or her work or in more
likely an independent film where
everybody's so excited to just get to
the end of the day of shooting and it's
something that they hope will shoot them
to the top in the industry but even if
not it's something they really really
wanted to do so in that sense this kind
of camaraderie I have seen happen and
independent feature films what is it
about a director that gives them sort of
the personable feel of a father-like
figure because you know we've heard of
great people great artists that there is
sort of a wall that's put up and maybe
it's by necessity you know I'm sure it's
gotta be difficult to always have people
trying to access you all the time and
need something from you but then there's
those that seem to know how to just make
each person that they're speaking to
feel special have you sort of seen some
of the traits yes I've seen all of the
above you know I've seen directors and
my films who get the crew very committed
to them I've seen directors who are very
precise in what they do and it's it's
comforting to me as a producer that the
director has sketched all the shots has
laid it out so everybody knows what
they're doing
I've seen you know scared directors so
it just yeah it's hard to say what would
make this kind of camaraderie happen or
not happen and when you're when you do
see this location that's just amazing
and it just all sorts of ideas come to
you are there certain things that you've
said you know what this is a no go aside
from maybe obvious sound issues but are
there certain things like do you have a
checklist like okay this is a very
beautiful locale I want to shoot here
but this is not going to work or this
looks right well expense
or weather or yeah there are a lot of
things to take into consideration as to
whether it would be possible to shoot at
the location or not and whether it's
worth it to take the gamble of whether
you can pull it off whether you'll
actually get the government sign off or
whether you'll actually you know be able
to get the tourist two stances Salvatore
well you know Oh in one case I remember
there was a location they said well this
is a nature preserve and you're welcome
to shoot here except that we have a
certain kind of a very rare crane that
is nesting and if it you know if there's
no more need for the nest in other words
if the you know if the baby is born and
the crane flies away from the nest you
can shoot there and otherwise no so so
did you have someone on the set
designated as a nest checker how did how
did you know I think it it just worked
out I did yeah it did yeah
you